con un mensaje de advertenciang realizó
el lanzamiento de dos misiles tan solo
unas horas antes del inicio de los
ejercicios militares conjuntos de seúl y
Washington este 13 de marzo los
simulacros denominados fueron shield son
de una escala sin precedentes desde 2017
los aliados dicen que es una respuesta
al aumento de las amenazas de Corea del
Norte
Ahora que Corea del Norte casi ha tenido
éxito en la miniaturización y la
fabricación de armas nucleares tácticas
más livianas
ya ha asegurado docenas de bombas Hemos
llegado a un punto en el que es difícil
justificar la lógica de que debemos
abstenernos de desarrollar armas
nucleares buscando la desnuclearización
Aunque algunos en Corea del Sur han
expresado su oposición diciendo que los
simulacros podrían Conducir a una
confrontación directa
creo que seguir realizando ejercicios
militares puede verse como un acto de
provocación para Corea del Norte
eventualmente podría convertirse en un
conflicto pyongyang dice que tales
ejercicios son ensayos para la invasión
de su territorio la misma justificación
que utiliza para seguir desarrollando su
programa de armas nucleares el líder
norcoreano Kim Jong ordenó a sus tropas
la semana pasada que intensificaran las
maniobras militares para simular una
guerra real y ha sido declarado como un
estado con armas nucleares una medida
que Kim llama Irreversible Corea del
Norte ha llevado a cabo una serie de
pruebas de misiles balísticos que viola
la resoluciones de la ONU